Hi everyone, in this video we're going to go ahead and continue what we were doing with
animating materials and jump in and show some of the options in which we can edit things
and get the look that we need.
So let's get started.
So jumping back into Unreal, we can see that we have our nodes set up here like we did
before.
I'm going to shuffle some of these things down a little bit.
We're going to kind of repeat what we did before and get things in the order that we
need.
This is all up to you visually how you want things to look.
We can combine looks, we can add things to make things a little bit more exaggerated.
And what I mean by that is maybe highlight the water a little bit more by pushing some
values and we can do a little bit of that when it comes to our loading things in to
our specular and our rough, which we're going to do here.
So first up, let's go and take a look at some of the options and some of the things we can
do for the specular slot.
Now we've put stuff in the middle slot and you don't necessarily have to do this for
this particular material.
But if you want to exaggerate things, you can add that.
It just depends how, what kind of values you want from the rock.
Now what I can do right now is maybe turn this off, disconnect this temporarily.
And we're going to go ahead and bring in and just move this off to the side.
So we'll do a comparable later.
And let's go ahead and bring in the other textures that we need for the specular.
Now for the specular, what we're using is that smooth texture again.
So let's go ahead and I'm going to select it.
I'm going to minimize this just a little bit here, pull this in so we have a little more
real estate.
I'm going to close my stats little window there and that actually tells me if things
are not connecting correctly.
So I grabbed my smooth and do control D. It'll actually duplicate it right where my cursor
is at, which we talked about before.
And we're going to go ahead and start connecting a few more things.
So let's go ahead and go in here and add the raindrops, but we're going to get the raindrops
that are a little bit more exaggerated dark and light.
So if we go back into our raindrops folder, let's go ahead and grab that one that says
metallic 02.
And we'll put that one up in here.
Now again, this isn't necessarily have to be connected to metallic.
I just did that for experimentation purposes.
So it's up to you how you want to do that.
And I'm going to go and combine these with a Lerp and I'm going to actually control how
strong that value comes through.
I'll show you what I mean.
So I came up here with a Piki again, but I make sure I do a negative one again for going
downward on our motion.
It's the same as we had before in the other pattern.
And I'm going to go ahead and punch this in to the UVs for the metallic raindrops and
for the more smoother one.
I'm also going to do it.
Now what can be helpful is we can use alert.
I keep my finger the L key and this linear interpret node takes 50% of each one of these,
kind of like 50.
50 does a nice little blend and gives us an alpha for overall control.
So I'm going to go and push these into one, the B value for the bottom one and the A value
for the top one.
And then we're going to get a water spec control.
And I'm going to keep my finger on the S key and I'm going to left click and this will
be our scalar parameter and we'll call this spec control right there.
And we'll keep that value at zero and that's fine for the default because we're going to
make an instance material.
I'm going to move that right into the alpha and then I'm going to move that right into
the spec.
So now we can kind of get a little bit of the same thing we had before, but favoring
So overall we can avoid maybe some of the unnecessary shininess that may occur from using a metallic
material.
The add does help mute things a little bit, but in this particular case, this should be
just fine.
And I'm going to move some of these textures down.
Let's move these down temporarily for a second.
And let's go ahead and fill out some of these other values.
Now what we can do with a rough is we can do a nice little experimental hybrid to get
maybe a little bit more wave movement going on.
What I mean by that is I'll show you that we can add another texture layer in here.
Now what I mean by layers in this particular case, I made it pretty loose.
We're going to just pretty much lay them on top each other in this case.
So first up, what we want to do is let's go ahead and make a roughness strength.
So I'm going to give my finger the S key and left click.
There we go.
And we'll call this rough strength.
And then we'll go ahead and keep a finger the M key left click and do multiply.
And then let's go ahead and pull in some roughness for the stones, the overall texture.
So we'll go back into that mega scans stone one, river stone, and we'll pull in the roughness
that we have.
Now if you already have it, I think in our case, we may have already have it.
There we go.
I think I pulled it in earlier.
No, that's the AO.
There's the roughness.
So we already have that in place.
So I'm going to move this guy away.
And this roughness, we're going to go and punch set into the B channel.
I'll multiply.
I'm going to put the rough strength into the E channel.
And we're going to now use a blend overlay.
Now typically what you can do, you can swap these out.
This basically uses a multiplier.
You multiply as one against the other.
So again, like we talked about before, it's similar to working with Photoshop.
So if I wanted to, I could even flip these and still kind of get the same effect in
this particular case.
And I'll leave those up there for now.
So let's go ahead and keep my finger the P key again.
And oh, my bad, I had a different key on that particular case.
Let's actually even duplicate so we can grab our pattern and keep my finger on control
D. And then we'll just go ahead and just duplicate what we have before.
That makes things a little bit easier.
So let's go ahead now and plug this into an overlay, blend overlay in which we can add
the raindrops.
So we'll call a blend overlay underscore overlay.
There we go.
Always forget there's underscore.
Right there.
And we're going to grab the raindrops and let's go ahead and grab the ones that we
need.
In this particular case, we're using that metal ones again that we pulled in.
And we'll go control D to get it.
Pull the panor in there and pull this into the blend overlay.
And we're going to go ahead and add another layer of extra wave movement.
So move this down.
Move this down too.
So let's go and get that extra wave movement going.
So we're going to grab another texture.
This particular texture is called water waves.
And you'll find that under step five.
So if we go down here, go to step five, you'll see water waves right there.
And I'm going to go and pull that into my scene.
Let's duplicate that pattern one more time.
So do control D and it'll show up wherever my cursor is at.
Reach that right into the UVs there.
And then now let's go ahead and blend this over all and bring it into our roughness.
So we've got a few more nodes.
One will do multiply.
Again, keep my finger the M key and left click there.
And then we'll do like a wave opacity.
So if we want to control this wave opacity, let's do a scalar parameter.
And we'll call this wave opacity.
Now again, you can type it in or you hit that S key.
And I'm going to pull that right into the B channel.
And I can keep that as a default as 0.5 and I can choose whether I want to max that out.
So let's go ahead and get the texture sample.
We just need the alpha information.
We don't need it on top of it.
So we're going to go and pull that into the A channel here.
And we'll get the add.
So let's get that add in there.
So I keep my finger the A key.
Add.
This is going to make it a little bit more brighter of a highlight.
I'm going to pull the multiply into the B channel.
And then I'm going to grab that blend overlay and pull it into the A channel.
And then now I can move that right into our roughness.
Now it can give us a little bit like an extra like it's like a wet.
Just a little more cartoony and that's fine.
And we can choose how that speed is going to go.
So this can give you a little bit more of that almost like that irregular pulsating
feel that you get from water.
The ripples basically is what we're trying to imitate.
And we can add that if we wanted to make a normal for that and add that in there too.
That's really up to you how you want to approach that.
That's it with this video.
And in the next video, we're going to wrap things up with a little more AO and some normals
to be able to animate.
Thanks again.